what's up guys we're here with the
official poison ivy character breakdown
from nether realm now this was taken
from a live stream so if you see
anything that seems a little off
remember that it's a work in progress
and don't forget to Like and subscribe
to keep up to date with all of our
injustice to coverage whoo
so we've got from the most part one of
the most hard to move she has is this
amazing dress right yes and so it'll
push the players back and it'll keep her
at that distance that she wants to be
what do you say Steven now like
Aquaman's from the deep it will actually
track where the opponent is you're not
doing a far one it's a homing move yeah
however um the meter bird one also comes
out on block so the opponent when they
block a vine drill they have to guess
are you doing a second vine guru or
you're just going to do the first five
no I do I get a dash after long yes
right right you can then try to get in
but uh it's a very very very powerful
hoping keep out yep right and then
another thing she has are these
grounders right so if she's just what I
guess come at me and you do decide to
get close to her she can put out traps
in front of her as well these uh Roberts
are going to do additional damage while
standing so even if the opponent does
advance past the blind drill the root of
the problem will be stayed in that bed
of thorns where there's a damage right
and then of course she hasn't kissed
and now she can also meter burn this and
that's a true throat
[Music]
and then from there you can go into
party time but we won't go into that
quite yet um she also has dark skin
right so which will actually have her
take my scanner so going into that
defensive stay away and it's pretty
significant right so you can be like all
right get back I'm gonna go ahead and
throw this out and then I'm gonna sit
here and go doesn't come at just
basically yeah right so a perfect
matchup example would be if you're doing
this against a doctor fee and you have
the bark skin on even if this projectile
is beating you and getting out before
the drill she's barely gonna take any
damage so he's still the onus is still
on him to come in right and then she
also has the hammer and from the hammer
you have multiple different attacks that
you can do to do a low kick you can do a
straight or an upper one in two straight
and then you can either burn it and go
in from all sides so it's just going to
do good chip damage if you have somebody
in the corner you've got cornered or
whatnot and then you can actually two in
one that was she's stuck in place during
that she is yeah she is so you're kind
of once you commit to it you're gonna
have well it here's a great place for it
cuz I'm in the corner right right yeah
and if somebody's trying to wake up you
can just go straight into it and wait
for him to wake up as well and then
probably my favorite part is nice shade
for little buddy
and so when nightshade does is basically
a torch so even if you get over or
behind me it's going to track
oh go on and you are not telling her
when to attack she's fully automatic
poison ivy is available just play the
game as you pleased while little pukey
is working doing your magic well in
actually nightshade button studio has
become cutie okay and so even if you
jump anything lucky is gonna get you
right and and this complements all the
special moves you just talked about so
why don't you have nightshade out you
can put on your bark skin and begin your
drills and the opponent is virtually
gonna keep out lockdown now here look
reset real flavor now pull out
nightshade alright put up and by if you
manage to make the correct decision and
hit IV nightshade will go away so one
hit and nightshades go run change so if
you're doing that this if this distance
that's not a great idea wreck it on the
right out right away um another thing
with with nightshade that's fun is if
you watch the meter right it's slowly
drinking it's basically how long's gonna
be around but right towards the end you
can send it out to do a low attack as
well that's what that what that was so
if you're just sitting and you're
letting do his attacks he can go okay
he's about she's about done let me send
you out for an attack which that block
just that which you block just then and
then as we hadn't talked about before
she's got a pretty strong mid game and
she's got these two plants that are on
her shoulders and I believe that's
Chompy and by chopping a body
don't be invited that is that that I
believe sir accessory yes yes those are
her accessories so you'll get new
different shopping by DS which I guess
you can name when you get different
right but uh um and these actually
extend her attacks so like we're saying
before she really doesn't touch you it's
more of Chompy inviting that dude and
they
normally I also do love her down - and
her back 3 which you her down - she's
not actually attacking at all on her
back three right so she's calling plants
- yes do new her bidding she also has a
very unique 4:3 that she can actually
control the distance up she can do it
long or short
so her 4 3 has a incredible amount of
range of she goals for that was the
short one yep yeah that's the normal one
and then and then look at that yes so um
for the most part she's kind of that
stay back character but if you get in
close she's gonna poke you and try and
make that distance can you show her back
- which in my opinion is kind of her
perky normal attack look at the range of
this and then it goes into this or if
you are pretty sure it's going to hit
you can do back to down - and then go
under your drill know yeah yeah that's
definitely her that's kind of her key
neutral game move nope going in - okay
another cool one which is a little
mix-up string is back 1 2 3 which begins
with a very fast low and then all the
way back right and she
it also has three one three very cool
looking
the second hit solo I love that last tip
and she does have a good mixture over
heads turns and different combos as well
right her she's one of those characters
were her mix ups come in the middle of
her pressure not just overhead low
static over him we also have a shorter
throw yeah it's a good one
just throwing out those kisses
she was definitely kiss slump Steve do
you want to see if you can nail your
swaggy combo okay I'm gonna try it all
right how many tries we're gonna give
Steve That's not me this time
oh I'm going to find you know tonight's
to come on are you tracking visually
three four be with let's cheer for you
Oh what are you doing here bird yeah
here Burt here better acting also with
ivy and odd pukey here right once you if
you're just gonna stay back but you want
to be right you can actually tackle and
then go into and pewt is gonna continue
from the other side right so pukey can
be a defensive move and if you have the
life lead there in a lot of trouble she
can just hide behind their barks but
like Derrick said if you need to make
the comeback if you're behind you he's
the perfect way to cover your advance
and then you can start using her long
range for three four double hitting jump
to her for two moves another good
advancing move one thing I'm excited
about this kinda like dorky high level
sucker like how we've kind of played
with some of the mechanics of our back
and four degrees in this game yes
certain carriers of different ways with
supergirls is very unique yes I think
that's really cool
the way she uses her bread because it's
such does a constant thing in our day
you go back very important we're very
hoarder our wall down for big how their
chains how those work is me super time
to time I'm excited this is a good one
that's that feed me alright even sloppy
good anything about that yeah I mean
it's all about keeping your opponent
away right in distance with her and just
drift right and if they get close she
can hand she could hit yeah she can
handle it but usually you're going to do
a quick combo to send them back to go
back to getting pukey out and doing your
drills either very a very definitive
gameplay style it's a very different
type of style
regim very very methodical you are gonna
if the pace is slow she's winning right
alright so let's check out what we did
with some of her outfits and what other
abilities or Gears or Gears I'm very
excited let's see what we got here and
you put those together yeah yeah yeah oh
nice
and so naturally as you'll see that
hurts honestly Derek and I we we set
these low tops for the girls yesterday
we spent probably longer than needed to
be a saloon making these slow two cuts
we'll have a jar talk to you alright so
as you see obviously her Chompy inviting
have changed cuz that's the accessory
piece and then the different abilities
we gave was one is the line problem
where she'll actually put her hands to
the ground summon
and this replaces the drill and it's a
great move because it covers even more
space vertically you can see it goes all
the way up and while this does not track
fullscreen this is actually better from
mid to close range and then the meet
upper one is two extra hits and covers
the hottest space this is an ultimate
screen control and of course it's
quitting on that again right which is
all okay and then the other one we have
is the thistle coat so instead of the
bark skin she now has little thorn
thorns right that go around her body and
when you do attacks you're doing more
damage and if she gets hit she'll do
damage to them as well so this replaces
the bark skin and it's literally the
exact opposite the bark skin is great if
you're playing her for her boiler play
keep out game but give it to match up
where that's not very effective and she
has no choice but to get in but he's
still on a player the whistle code is
great because if the opponent's in and
they're damaging you you're getting hurt
too right then beauty of a match that
could cause ya oblems you can see like
the damage injuries
it's pretty significant um and those are
basically the two and different
abilities that we added onto her and
then here we go to loadout number three
oh we got here so this is nice
yeah leave that that's pretty good so on
this one she has the Demi thorns where
is actually another projection so and
this is a traditional projectile we can
go into this into this and also have
media all the time so this gives her be
just prototypical standard fireball she
doesn't normally have normally she's
more controlling the ground so this is
allows her to control the space in front
of her and the meter bird one is just
very good multiple hits good damage and
that this really compliments for place
vilest especially against a character
who as a good projectile himself because
now she has a fast projectile right and
then the additional one is petals of
life and while she's standing in the
area she's can she's continuously
getting popped back right and this this
replaces uh the thorns that go on the
ground ground ball right so if you are
doing the stay back and you have low
health but you have all this things
protecting you because that's basically
how she is it's putting all these things
out to protect her you can bring this up
you can meter burn it and now it's doing
even more help can I point out how much
I love the animation
that's perfect so and of course she has
additional ability moves that we're not
going to get into bus that's poison ivy
she basically wants to stay back and let
her plants do the work
yes get close Chompy and bitey are going
to come after we actually funny enough
we did have some matches before he
started stream where we were playing
Grodd versus quiz night in which when
you got me in the back I was having
trouble right but when I got close to
you I do so much significant damage we
were having lunch right and I was like I
gotta get away right hello
so you actually good got to see that
sort of the real classic machen
I gotta get in you